And
Tastic welcome to the very first lead manager training playbook. I think it might be the name of it
I can't remember the lead man in the lead manager playbook turning marketing dollars into closed deals, okay?
Kylie can you I'm gonna give you a host here
Can you try to get your fireflies in here if you don't mind? I'm gonna give you co-host
Because I'm not I'm afraid yesterday the challenge didn't really not the challenge the
By weekly didn't record even though mason click record, so I'm gonna be safe
so
What we're gonna be covering today is in a way I'm positioning this is we do a lot of work through the deal flow challenge through our other
Challenges through our you know by weekly is we have a lot of information out there on how to actually generate leads
I think we like by far we're the best people to learn and understand how to do that the cheapest most effective way possible
and
What we've never spent a ton of time on is how to actually do the lead management function and convert those leads into to close revenue
We have a lead manager training. We've covered in some challenges in the past. We've never really dug deep into that ecosystem
About the different features that we have within the product to do this and so I've spent the last
four weeks or so
Really delving deep into this and thinking about you know, what is this what is our current default build look like?
And where are the gaps in the understanding of lead management across our user base?
Obviously not all of our users use sift entirely as a CRM some use others and I want to let you guys know if you're one of those people
That's no big deal like you can just take this information if you want to build it out in that other CRM
Then by all means do that what I'd be a little offended
Maybe but at the end of the day who cares about my feelings, right?
You guys do whatever you want to do, right? Just take our information use it and as long as you're managing your data to generate the leads
It's the thing I care the most about all right, but just know that this is universal across everything what I'm gonna be covering with you is not
you know
Necessarily just sift related here. I'm covering a lead manager playbook. I'm talking about what is a lead manager?
What should they be doing and I'm gonna be
Intently focused on the the building and inside sift, but again replicate that put it somewhere else the core philosophy and everything is still there
Okay
what's gonna come with this from a resource perspective is you guys are gonna get a
A folder of resources that are a bunch of MD files that I personally curated and spent a lot of time asking questions and
Using my experience taking a ton of my
Conversations and processes over the years and dumbing it down to the most important critical information to build out a new updated playbook
Around our custom fields for example, how many here go ahead and put it in the chat
How many here are currently using custom fields in sift right now for lead management?
Who knows knew that we even had custom fields that's something that we have an issue with too, okay?
It might not be anybody, right?
So Dave is fantastic
We got 76 custom fields that we're gonna be looking at today
So quite a bit, okay
Every one of them have a place and a meaning and in in all of its stacks on top of it
And I have a skill that I've created to where you guys don't have to create all 76 of those right
It'll just go in there and Claude will create every single one of them for you
I've
Reverse engineered it essentially where Claude is actually gonna link into an API that doesn't exist quote-unquote in order to
Build all those for you so that it goes really fast, okay?
and so
We use it for first-market extra data and not lead management. Yeah, so custom fields can be used for all data-centric stuff
But we what we want to do is when we have we got to think of our organization a little bit differently
I want you guys to
Think about the fact that like everybody's a lead manager
Everybody's a data manager everybody's in acquisition
Everybody's job inside the organization is a move somebody from no money to money in our bank account, all right?
And so if a cold caller is doing actions and activities the information that they gather is
Being pushed down the line right now all of this information from cold callers and first-market stuff and you know
From our call tools and everything else that goes into like the message board
We want to take the critical information out of there and we want to move that into custom fields
One of the biggest most important reasons for this is because of other skills
Such as underwriting. It's a it's a lot more difficult to automate and build AI agents and skills based off information
That's in a paragraph
But if I have a custom fields folders that are that are broken down based on what they mean in their intent and their purpose
Then I can use my underwriting skill and I can have it go through and I can see these very specific
Answers and information to be able to very quickly really accurately generate an underwriting or offer
Assumption on the deal. Okay, so
as we progress through
Pulling the data communicating with the seller and moving them down that pipeline
Custom fields are very important because it tells us what information that's the core information for us to do business with this seller
What do we have and what don't we have for example?
When do you want to sell?
Are you the decision maker?
Is there any back taxes? Is there any encumbrances? What's the mortgage bounce?
Right we want to not leave this to someone manually typing
their brain to an input field to answer that question
Because you'll get a different response every single time and in data management. What we love is uniformity
Okay, and lead management. We love uniformity in acquisitions. We love uniformity because our
Operation our business is a funnel. It's a it is a conveyor belt and we want to try to take the core of what the business is
And we want to make sure that we are
Automating and building processes around the core parts of the business the core questions the core answers and making sure it's
Systematically the same for everybody
Because this makes our team more efficient it makes our data more accurate and it allows us to create filters in
The future that allows to dig deeper into the people that we're getting in contact with for example I
generated a new lead and
They want to sell within 30 days. They're on the probate list and the custom field for
Are they the decision maker is no
You know like
I have a thousand prospects like this person wants to sell in 30 days
But they're not the decision maker and so this tells me okay
This probably needs to go to deep diving right and so there's a ton of different edge case and you create a thousand of them right but
Custom fields is the only way
That we can actually create the process to take our thousands of leads
Actual leads not prospects, but leads that you generate over time and out of the
55 plus percent are gonna be cold leads
How do I prioritize who I need to pluck in and spend a lot of attention on because some of my leads
I should be sending mail to every single month
Maybe not all of them, but some of them
I want to send mail to because that might be the only way I get in contact with them convert them back to engage again
All right
And the same thing is true with our ghosting leads if something moves to ghosting
How do I determine which ghosting leads deserve most of my priority?
The only way we do this is insight and levers to pull and the only levers that we have is the information
We gather from the sellers and if we don't organize this in a great way
Then it's becomes useless for us, right?
Okay, so
Let's get into it custom fields. We're gonna get into a lot of them all that to say. Oh, yeah exports
So so you're gonna get a training manual. This is gonna be a PDF document version that you guys can update
It's gonna be a HTML version which I'm gonna be used as my as my slides today essentially
And then there's gonna be a daily workflow. There's gonna be a QC process file
There's a script summary
There's drip campaigns file. There's
You're based in cloud file, which I'll cover that
and
What you'll be able to do is
Create a folder put all this information there and if you want to ask questions like I'm doing this right now
How can I improve it?
It'll be able to answer that question for you based upon the core standard practices that I know will work for you, okay?
especially
the lead manager
Breakdown that explains. What is a lead manager? What do they do? What are the responsibilities?
What filters should they be focused on and all that other kind of stuff, okay?
to include
Some conversational type stuff like if you're gonna ask questions about the roof. What question should you ask?
right
Okay, so
Let's get into it
So I'm gonna share my screen
This file the resources and all that stuff
Once we get done this one and all these stack on top of each other just like I do from the market analysis training
Every single week. These are gonna be done bi-weekly, right? So every bi-weekly
There's a huge chance. There's new content new information
All the recordings will be in the help center underneath
Folder which will include the link to the resources to download the skills and stuff, okay?
right
So
Can you guys see that okay
Yes
All right
So this is where we're covering. This is the lead manager
training, all right, and
It's broken down into eight different modules. The first one's gonna be talking about what is the lead manager role, okay?
Why does it exist?
I this is literally the floor to cash real estate one
It's another thing to understand is you guys are gonna get a skill in that folder
If you upload that skill to Claude if you want to do this you don't have to you can just take the that's why I'm giving you guys a word
Document to okay because the word document you guys can just manually update
But if you want Claude to do work for you and you want to use AI the skill you can just say in it
It asks you a series of questions
You tell it what your company name is what your name is what your lead manager's name is and it will go through and I'll update this
For your training manuals for your company
So you don't got to build this all yourself
It just update everything and then just have your lead manager watch this training as well as you know go through the manual
Okay, so we know about but what is the role we operate as a full-service real estate business if you don't
Then you guys can change that right, but we're a full service. We'll explain what that means in a minute
It's gonna talk about your toolbox
The stab a method all this stuff's gonna talk about the lead flow
We're gonna talk a little bit about the day of a lead manager
We're gonna talk about custom fields and how does a lead manager process a call?
Okay
We're talking about quality control
So this is a lead manager or their manager and how do you QC to make sure that everything is where it's supposed to be?
So you never make sure that
leads get left behind and all this other good stuff
And then we're talking about KPI tracking
Inside of your
This is really a different kind of training. I'm trying to decide if I should embed it into this training or create a whole another
training around it, but I do have in my business we have a KPI tracking where all of the the lead summary and the
KPI metrics from the lead manager
I get a daily report in Slack that tells me the efficiency and the bottlenecks of the lead management team
And so it's a bit complicated to kind of bring into a training like this
But again, maybe I'll wrap that into one of the later versions of this once we kind of get down the get down the flow of this call
Because the first few are always a little messy, okay
But for now I'm gonna talk about what KPIs need to be tracked
And what in which ones matter and the percentage breakdowns, okay, and then we're gonna get a drip campaigns everybody's
You know kryptonite or my kryptonite
I should say everybody else's chocolate in my kryptonite. All right
So let's go ahead and get into the first part of this. All right
What is the role? Okay, and I'm literally gonna read this document. Okay, so my voice is gonna be burned into your guys's brain
Probably by the end of this but I want this to be as detailed as possible and as you guys have questions
You know, just put them in the chat and we'll discuss it
But this is meant to be like an open dialogue kind of training here
We're really digging in think of it more like a workshop than a training, okay?
All right, so what we do as Florida cash real estate
We are a full service real estate business. We buy houses from motivated sellers renovate them and either sell them to end buyers
Or add them to our rental portfolio. The lead manager is the engine that makes the entire operation work
And I mean that very very literally a lead manager in my opinion is by far the most important asset the most important role inside your organization
More important than the acquisitions person more important than the cold call of themselves
Okay, because your leads most of your deals will come from people from three months plus ago
Not within the week that you called the people, okay?
Follow up follow up follow up follow up is so so critically important
It is the most important thing inside the business. There's no question about it
And so they are the most important person and this is why
You know, if you don't have a lead manager, you know
And you are that lead manager if you're not generating deals, it could be because of your lead management process
100% in my experience when I have people who say like oh sift stinks at being a CRM blah blah blah blah blah blah
I'm like, okay
Let's go look at your operation. I would say 99% of the time
It's they have a ton of tasks that are overdue
They're not doing the task that's supposed to be doing and not just showing up to do the job, right?
And so what happens can anybody guess what they do instead?
What is it that they they move to?
What do they end up doing because they're not getting deals and they feel like they have a bottleneck in lead management quote unquote
What is it that their source of fixing that problem is?
More leads, yep
what else
They offload the lead management to what my kryptonite?
automations
Right they end up saying okay
Well, just drip campaign everything so they move to like go-high level or some other tool where when a lead is generated
There's no actual follow-up from a lead manager and instead they just drip them until the person's willing to suddenly be like
Okay, cool. Let me just get on a phone with you
And just you just give me your offer and I'll just you'll just sell you the house for 50 cents on a dollar
As if no relationship they move from like they move right from
I seen you across the bar a hundred yards away to like we're married in the matter of 30 minutes
Without even talking to the person and it's just not how business works, you know, it's like that
You know, you have to nurture you have to call you have to build a relationship
Now the argument here for most people is but Tyler. They just want an offer. Okay, then give them an offer
That's part of the relationship sometimes, you know
There's there's a time to sit down and talk for 30 minutes and go on a day and
Communicate and talk about your stories and your life and blah blah blah blah blah
And there's a time where that's not the case and the relationship is very transactional
Right and and you just got to understand
Which is why drip campaigns can be terrible for you is because it doesn't have the context to know what is
The situation they can't read the room
You know and so again the lead managers so critical they own they own every lead in the system
I don't care if it got moved the acquisitions when a lead moves to acquisition
The lead manager has the authority of that of that prospect of that lead, right? And so if you move a lead from
Warm to send to offer and that offer is not given in the next 48 hours
The lead manager can go up to that acquisition person go swap swap
back on the side of the head because
They just ruined that relationship
Because the lead manager made a promise and the acquisition person broke that promise
They said you're gonna get it off with the next 24 hours. What happened? No offer came no communication
And this is why your leads go dead
Because the handoffs aren't there so earlier when I said that everybody is a lead manager
What I'm what I'm referencing to is that?
Everybody's job in the organization is to pass on and make the next person seem amazing
Handoffs are so critical your data person your cold collar your cold collars to say awesome
Well, thank you so much for this information one of my most hated lines is
I'm gonna pass this off to my partner
You you really think that this person thinks that you have a partner that you're passing us off to and
Do they really care that it's a partner?
Right they don't do that the conversation instead would be okay awesome Sally
I really appreciate your time today. What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pass this your information over to Jay Jay is our
lead manager
He's gonna actually reach out to using together a little bit more information confirms some information so that when we get you over to our
Tim our
Acquisitions to make your offer we make sure that we understand everything that's going on with you
So we can present our you know three at least three different solutions to make sure that we can you know help you out
Right like like you use the names turn it emotional Jay and Tim those are real people my partner
Right this is a bunch of BS
Because you're trying to pass over authority as a caller. They don't care about your authority. You just talk to them for two minutes
Like it doesn't matter the lead manager's job is to nurture that person until they're they're they're ready
And if you hand them off and they know Jay is who who's calling them or they know it's either gonna be Jay or Timmy
Right, then then that's what you should do. Okay. So the handoff is really critical the information that's gathered and how well it's passed on is
Very very important. All right
All right, so most people here we buy houses and think that we've low ball distress owners
That is not what we do. We solve real problems for real people
Okay, homeowners dealing with foreclosure probate divorce code violations or properties. They simply cannot afford to maintain
We are problem solvers
investors second
This is what I say in my business, right? This is again. This is our our our training manual
Embedded into this HTML document. Okay, and so
Really really critical to understand and make sure your team understands who you are and what you do and your lead manager has to be able to echo
Echo this voice
Okay
What's up? I don't know your name. I just know alpha
Hey, what's up time to do this is Freddy with alpha Bravo. Hey a quick question
So you mentioned the handoff you say my partner
Tyler it will be contacting you, but we have multiple
Acquisition managers that could be reached now. They don't round robin for these leads
How are you handled that set off what they don't know who will be calling them?
Yeah, so first of all most we don't say partner. We tell them the role
So I don't like the partner part because it's a lie, right?
I don't like I'm not gonna seed
Lies into the way that we do business, right? It's just a bad way about doing things for me
Um, so it depends on where it's at like if it's the cold collar that's doing a transitionary phase like there's different phases to every conversation, right?
Um, cold collars they stop at you know step three of a qualifying phase
Right and then it hands off to a lead manager in that in that handoff
Um, if you have multiple lead managers first of all
Um, based on what you just said about acquisitions people
It's important that if I don't have a lead manager that I need a lead manager
And the lead manager only sends people to acquisitions that are ready for an offer
Acquisitions people should only be doing
two things
making initial offers and following up for the next like five to
10 days on people that
Have an answer to get that initial offer
Once that offer is given it's either accepted or rejected or they're thinking about it
We'll follow up with that offer for another three to five days
And if they have not made a decision, it's getting kicked back to lead management
Um, you should have like two lead managers per single
Acquisition before you ever need another acquisitions person for example, okay, so just keep that in mind
So if I have multiple lead managers and it's being handed off from a cold collar to multiple lead managers
Then, um, I'm just gonna reference their names
Of course, if it's more than like five then that's going to be a little excessive but to be a really
a very good organization
Two lead managers can maintain
Uh, enough leaves like we have one and we and we do 10 contracts a month one lead manager and one acquisition
you know, and so um
I think it's really important to make sure that if we're operationally fluid
We'll have to be able to have less people and the company can maintain more revenue, right?
Um, but nonetheless the end of the conversation would be something like
Um, you know, hey, um, uh, uh, hey arthur. I appreciate all this time and information
You're giving me what i'm going to do now is i'm going to pass your information
over to either j or um, danny or
Brint and they'll be reaching out to you. Uh, one of those three, but i'm not going to be like
Um, you know, i'm not going to list out like 10 names, you know, um, it gets to the point where there's a lot
Um, I would just summarize it up to being, you know, i'm going to either danny or
Um, or tyler's going to reach out to you. Someone from our lead management team
Um, whoever's, you know, quick is available. Uh, we'll reach out just keep an eye out from our our company number out of blank
Right. Um, so it'd be like, uh, all of our numbers are out of 850 for the most part
Uh, and so keep out from uh from a number from 8 from an 850 number that you don't recognize
Um, uh, we'll text you before we call
Right. Um, so that's another really big thing. Uh, making sure they know like, hey, you'll receive a text before we call
We'll let you know it's our number and then uh, we'll give you a holler and and so, uh, make sure you pick up
And sometimes that's like the difference between increasing your like your lead management, uh, qualifying percentage
It's like setting up for success, you know, we have a
Um, over a 50 percent lead qualifying percentage
A lot of people stay down in like the 20s because like they're not doing the right amount of effort to get that new lead on the phone
Or they, um, you know, they're not doing that handoff properly and setting the expectation because otherwise you leave it to assume
You know, like the seller if the seller doesn't know what to expect next then it's really difficult for them to do what you expect them to do
For you, right? And so it's really important to let them know
This is the next thing to expect from us
And it's like it's like if it has anybody ever went into like
I'll give it a scenario here like go shop for a watch at walmart versus rolex
Right, what is the difference in experience there that you're gonna that you're gonna, you know, have when you walk into rolex
Number one you you can't just walk into the rolex dealer most of the time you you know, depending on where it's at if it's in a mall
You gotta like stand in line and sometimes I'll look at you and be like, oh, well
You're not coming in, you know, and they just kind of tell you to walk away
You know, otherwise you go inside
Someone greets you and that you get prompted with the the they put you down a conveyor belt
Right, they know exactly they they ask you the right qualifying questions
And they put you through what they know is successful to get you to walk out with a watch or
For rolex or most watch dealerships. It's just to put your name on a list
They're gonna wait for 12 months to call you
And so so experience is really important. You can associate it with mcdonald's versus a fine dining restaurant whatever people like
Clarity people like to know
What is next in the in their experience with you?
They like to feel like they're being put up on a pedestal and they're getting that concierge service if
Thank you for the information. Someone will be in touch and you hang up
You've just made them feel as though they just went through a Wendy's, you know drive through
You know, and they'll you know, maybe you'll call back again
You know, so just be very careful with that
So
The next thing is a lead manager understanding where leads come from right um for us leads into the business from four primary
Sources each have a different profile and urgency level. All right direct mail
I feel like I got a sneeze by the way, so you guys might oh, it's like right there. Don't you guys hate that? I can feel it. It's not
This has gonna bother me
Okay, I think it's gone
That's the worst. Okay, so direct mail
um is the first one right postcards and letters targeted lists, um sellers respond to calling or
texting these are warm inbounds
they
Initiated contact process through smartphone inbox, right?
So the way we do things is our direct mail numbers are on smartphone or through smartphone
And so as we'll continue reading here
One of the first things that lead managers need to do is they need to go in a smartphone
They need to see was there any inbound phone calls to our direct mail number if there was they're gonna you know call back those
Numbers by prioritizing those that leave a voicemail
They're gonna look in the inbox because maybe someone texted it
Right and they're gonna respond back those text messages and process those new leads. Okay
Um, the second most important is uh cold calling. These are our outbound team
These are outbound generated and so on. I'm not gonna dig into each one of these and you have our carrot website and then ppl
So these are our four sources of leads that come into our business direct mail co-calling seo
In ppl
Okay, now our carrot website depending on what's going on our facebook leads if we're doing facebook that all comes in through carrot
Okay, so it's all summarized underneath of that one thing
Okay
Okay, so what is our role as a lead manager? You're the first human touchpoint in the sales cycle
Okay, your job is to take every lead that enters the business and move it through a structured qualified
Qualification process until it either becomes an appointment for the acquisition specialist or exits the pipeline
Okay
So what is the eggs in the pipeline and what is the sending it to a specialist?
Right? What is the difference between that the actions and who who does what and what goes where we're going to continue to cover that?
Okay
So the core goal of every in interaction
End with either an appointment set for the specialist or a confirmed follow-up with the date
Okay, the lead manager if you speak to somebody again like I said earlier hand off hand off hand off. Okay
Seller I I appreciate your time today. I know you're super busy
Um, so what i'm going to do is i'm going to i'm going to
Tim i'm going to push you over to Tim. I've gathered a lot of information from you. Um, Tim is going to again
He's going to confirm a little bit of the information
We like to make sure that we're we're being very diligent and we don't waste your time
So he's going to confirm some information with you. Um, he's going to come to get come with you with some options already though
So he's going to confirm some information
Um, and he's going to come to you with some options typically
Between one and three that best suit what we can tell is the situation you have going on what we've discussed
Um, so be ready to receive a call from him next 24 to 48 hours
Okay
If for whatever reason you talk to anybody between now and then please give me a call back
So I can get on Tim to hurry his butt up. It is me against him
Right that's i'm not telling the seller that i'm just letting you guys know he's a lead manager against the acquisitions team
Uh, uh in the sense that I am with the seller because at the end of the day
When the acquisitions person makes an offer that the seller doesn't like
That that lead is going back to lead management and now the lead manager has to play the game
What what do you mean he gave you a low offer?
I told him the situation now did he give you like a cash offer and then give you some other solutions
Because I you know I see here
You know the property does need a roof right he does need this and and that rapport is going to then be used to try to remake the seller
Understood that it's not a low offer. It's what the offer should have been
You know and so the lead manager is to maintain the rapport right
And if it's not going to go to an acquisitions person right away, then it's okay. Well, I understand like you still need a few weeks
Um, this is what I'll do. I'll just follow up with you in two weeks from now. Um, around this same time
Right and and so they know and expect my conversation
Um, so while they go to sleep tonight
It's not a I spoke to that person. It's a that person told me they're gonna follow me in the next two weeks
Right and so the expectation is there so when I receive the phone call
I can hold to my promises and when I open that next conversation. It's hey, how's it going?
Whether it's a voicemail or it's a text message or it's I've actually spoken to them. I'm saying hey
I uh, I said I'd follow up with you in two weeks. I didn't want to you know
We like to maintain our word here and make sure we're doing the best that we can to make sure we don't lose confidence from you here
Um, uh, how's things going?
And then you pull in the rapport last time that we spoke you had mentioned that you were going to be going on vacation for the next week
So we couldn't do anything then how is vacation?
Don't jump right into the meat and potatoes of things right use your rapport and and have a genuine conversation has some empathy
Um, which is very difficult for me to have so that's why I'm not a greatly manager
but, um, with setting a process you can follow it to the t okay
Um, so no lead should ever sit without an x-action. There is no third option
Okay, meaning that they either go to acquisitions
Or they have a task on it
That's the two outcomes
Um, there's not a third besides leaving the funnel, right?
Okay, you are not making offers or closing deals
You are gathering intelligence on the seller's situation and maintaining consistent follow-up and making sure no lead ever sits without an action
You are the bridge between marketing which generates the leads in acquisitions, which makes offers and closes the deal
Okay
So it's really important, uh, this little section right here
You'll be amazed on how many lead managers do not fully understand that this is their job
Okay, they just do a task and they do it like at 50% what you need them to do
And they're not willing to step up and do it fully
Which means you have a bad culture fit you hired the wrong person
Okay
All right, so what is our toolbox inside data sift?
Um, on the default bill. This is the bill that every single account is automatically
Uh automatically generated with when you create a sift account and if you don't have this our support team can
Press a button and load all this in your account for you. Okay
Now i'm going to be covering a couple things today. The first is the default build
The second is once you've proven to show up every single day
What can you do to even compound and build on top of that default build?
Okay, um such as drip campaigns, okay
Because the system doesn't come with drip campaigns created out of the box because people should not be doing those out of the box
And you also require setting up integrations and other things and making those choices
So it's really difficult to do that out of the box. Okay
So every data sift account ships with a complete framework for managing your sales cycle
This default build was developed through direct collaboration with six and seven figure investors
Your job is to learn and operate it then improve it over time
I am telling you now whether you're an existing operation in another crm or not like
This is a proven system and process
That will make you money if you just follow it step by step and don't create and change things
Get used to it bake it into the business
Flow through it promise you it works 10 contracts a month
Okay
50 leads a week minimum from our team
Through just first to market. All right and and and we we flow through the leads. It's i'm telling you it's possible
You can even mess up
And as long as you follow like 50 percent of this like you will still close deals
But if you really dial in your operations, you're doing as well, um, you'll close way more
All right. So very first thing is can ban boards. All right. This is our default boards
Inside of sif line
Lead management acquisitions transactions wholesale flips and rentals. That's what you could you get out of the box. Okay
Property statuses. This is where your records sit in the sales cycle
Okay, new lead no contact new lead
Um cold warm hot ghosting lead dead leads not interested under contract and closed that is your
Um, your sales cycle
Don't go creating anything crazy. Don't go being like well. I underwrite deals. So i'm going to add an underwrite status
No
That's a task
not a status
You never change a status when something becomes a lenance in the pipeline
This will be the only thing when something says i am interested in selling then this will be the status until it dies
And turns into a deal for somebody else if you miss out on it. Okay, really important
Um, you don't go create a bunch of crazy stuff. Okay
There is other statuses that exist inside your account that but they're toggled off by default
Okay
Task presets. These are pre-configured follow-up actions with assignees and due dates
So like by default, it's assigned to the sensei so whoever created the account
So if you have a lead manager when you add that lead manager to your account
You're going to go into the lead management folder and you're going to assign those tasks to them
Right. So as an example
Let's go into data set real quick
I'm going to log in
All right, we're going to turn on sensitive
Sensitivity mode here
I
Do it, okay
All right, let me zoom in a little bit here
All right, so when I go to my um
My event system here and click on presets
You'll see the default builds that are created under lead management
You're going to click edit and you're going to change it from sensei
To user around robin and then whoever that first lead manager is
The reason why I do user around robin instead of clicking on user and choosing the person
Is because with user around robin in the future if I hire another lead manager. I can just add them in here for around robin, right?
I don't have to change it again. I just choose the person. All right, so
By default your account is built with all the tasks that you're needed
But you need to edit those tasks and make sure you update them with your lead manager that you want
Most likely though, most of you are the lead manager
But if you do have a lead manager, then you're going to want to put them in there, okay
We'll come back to that stuff. Okay
All right sequences
Sequences you don't need to touch and so you get to the point where you're going to build on top of what is already built inside the default build
There's 27. I think sequences or something like that. I think it might be 26
The
If you touch these or you touch the sipline boards or you change status names and you do random stuff
You're going to break your sequences and people get pissed off out of us
You won't believe it
I mean, maybe you will believe it but people literally get angry at my support and they mess with like wow
Well, my stuff's broken. You guys suck like this is terrible
Like because they went in and deleted a board
My sequences aren't working. Well, no
Of course, they're not
The board that was in the sequence is gone because you decided to delete it
Right like I can't fix the actions that you do
I can just give you what it is and you can learn this and you can apply it
And once you get sophisticated enough you can come in you can change some things
And I don't want people to think that you can't customize stuff
But I just want to stress upon how important it is to not just do the stuff just because I want dopamine
Right and again, not your atypical potential like words coming out of somebody who's doing a presentation
And I get people that say like oh Tyler's being egotistical and blah blah blah
I don't feel like I'm in a safe space like
Listen like I want you guys to succeed and in order for you to succeed
I've already done all the groundwork. We've done the groundwork. We know it works
Okay, and and and I just need you guys to follow it. Okay
And then build on top of it
So be careful about expanding the system
Do not create new statuses tasks phases just because you feel like you need them
This isn't just for you guys. I'm speaking to you guys because like I mean most of you are the business owners
But you won't believe how many of your team members will just do
Your team members should not just be doing
If they want something updated they have an idea ideation
There's a reason why you have team meetings
Bring the ideation to the table and be like hey, I think it'd be really good if we apply this
But they might not know about the thing on the other side of the company that relies on that process
And so then they change it
And now you have this big hiccup in your business
Where one department now is like, why is this not happening? I don't know. I'm expecting this thing and it's because somebody had an idea
and implemented it within 15 minutes
and it broke everything
And
It's all because like the proper channels and processes didn't go through in order to build operations
Versus just like everything's important
Right everything is not important. All right. The default build was designed to focus on what matters
Expanding without understanding why it's built. Um, this is why we create clutter
Break automations and make your pipeline harder to manage
Okay, be very very careful on editing this default build
Okay, um
You get stuck in a trap. I promise you you get stuck in a trap. Just be very careful. All right
All right, so the non-negotiable habit you guys have heard me say it stab them
I've updated stab them
Is a new word instead of tat instead of the a being part of task. I've added a signing
Makes way more sense
Um, so every time you open a record or leave a record you run the stab them flow, okay
This is not important to say this is not a qc audit step
It is a proactive habit on every record you touch
qc stands for quality assurance by the way in case anybody doesn't know that okay, this is a quality
This is not a quality assurance step. This is a making sure quality assurance doesn't find problems
This is that everybody in the business has a responsibility
When I enter into a record I stab them. I make sure it's where it's supposed to belong
Your business will always be better if you follow this, okay?
Um
If you stab them every time on the way in and out of a record
You are doing quality control in real time throughout your day, which means whoever's doing actual quality control
Will be a lot happier and a lot less frustrated because it's really annoying when your team
Doesn't do this and then you feel like the bad guy because every time you go to a record
Something's wrong
They didn't do something. They didn't add their messages. They didn't document their task or they didn't do something, right?
Um, and so your team could start feeling like you're a bully
Because you're like, oh, well, you keep telling me all the things that are wrong
And there are all the things that are right like well if you start doing more things that are right it wouldn't be a problem
You know, and then so it's like um
It's like if we build habits
It makes it towards no, it's not so much uh, you're doing things wrong
But it feels like it's just the right thing to do period like if you don't do the stab on process
Then it's like I just feel like I messed up, you know, so um really important
Okay, so stab them prevents
um
Problems from accumulating
Which is the biggest thing you want to do you want your operation to be fluid and consistent and you want
Things right all the time. There's never going to be perfect
But we can sure as heck get really close
Okay
All right, so status is matched uh phase mismatches
um orphaned records
um
Records with two tasks on them like there's very few times when a record should have more than one task on it during the lead management process
There's got multiple tasks on it. That means somebody before you didn't do their job
right
All right, so
Let me look at the messages here and see what's going on here in the chat stab them with ninja stars exactly
Book an appointment from an appointment assuming you put anyone that isn't truly motivated into cold drip
Um, if they're not truly motivated. They're not even they're not a lean
Difference like what is cold? What is warm? What is hot? What is a dead lead? What is not interested?
You know like the definition of what that means we're about to get into actually
Um, so yeah really important
Should cold leads have drip campaigns. I know I don't think so
Um ghosting leads and not interested um should have cycles of follow-up
um
The only time that I think a cold lead see you know cold lead should have actual drip campaigns is if um
If you don't want to hire another lead manager
Um, then they should have drip campaigns and then they should do that, but the natural progression just so everybody knows
You're going to scale to a point where you have two different lead managers have two different focuses
One is folks on unqualified follow-up. The other is folks on qualified follow-up
So the the person that you hire first that's an experienced lead manager essentially gets promoted into the qualified follow-up bucket
That is their job
the person who is
Newer will do unqualified follow-up and will also handle the ghosting lead follow-up and the
Not interested follow-up the leads that went from being a lead to being not interested
Right, and so you end up creating two separate lead managers with two separate
um skill sets and focus on the way that they qualify and build rapport
Right initial qualifier and um in the next one
Hey tyler, I was the one who asked the question about the cold drip
Theoretically so newly comes in through, you know cold calling or texting the lead manager has the conversation
So that's what i'm saying at that point
The only the only motivation that's there that's there is like, oh, yeah, i'm just gonna sell if I get you know x number x number makes
No sense for a wholesale, but like there's no other uncoverable motivation
So that's why i'm asking is it then just like all right. Let's not force it here
Yes, so this is this is kind of a business decision here like in that example
Again, it's the question on what is a cold lead qualifier for me that wouldn't be a cold lead that would just be
a dead lead probably in my business
um
Dead leads have different
Reasonings on them because what?
Okay, um, so let me let me step backwards
Cold call this whole area. You know, and they're just kind of verifying for a pulse
You know more or less is the only house are you open to an offer on it?
It then comes in lead lead manager has the conversation
The ultimate end of the conversation is there's no real motivation, you know, there's there's two different kinds of motivation though
Um, which what so so I think I covered in here, but let's let's talk about it real quick
um, there is
sellers
Defined motivation like what they're telling you like i'm not interested unless you give me this much or like I want this much money for it
but
They're going to auction in 30 days
right and so
Um, the question is is this like is there no other indicators?
Like you said there's no other indicators of motivation and this is just like
You know an owner occupied address that has high equity and they're saying that they want 650,000 for it
Then it's a dead lead. It's not really a lead right. Um, so i'm not going to put them as not inch
They're most likely they're actually to move the not interested right because they're not actually interested in selling
This isn't a true lead the cold caller
Gave us a lead that isn't that should have never been sent to waste the lead manager's time to begin with so
This is a problem of qualifying on the on the caller side
Um, now if they say they want 650,000 but it's on a probate list and you know
Uh, it's an absentee and the heirs own it
Um, then it's like, okay, this isn't going to work for a cash offer
But would this work for a listing if you're a full service agency then then sure I can list properties for you
Um, so therefore it is a lead and so so the definition of what we're calling a lead or not a lead is definitely important to define in the business
um
For me in our operation
If you say that you're interested in selling
Uh, the house we do consider you a lead
Um, because we do have multiple ways to to to close the deal
um
And once it gets to the lead manager of this person's just like off and left field
Um, meaning that like they want well above even what it could list at then we just move these people to dead leads
And we put them as unrealistic expectations and we just move on our lives. Yeah
Um, and then one other question, uh, another thing that I come across a decent amount are people that have like a second house
So they're rental property and it's more or less like
Like I've come across this probably five times this quarter or quarter one or whatever
We're like they'll sell it but they have to identify the other property that they want to move into first
So like yeah, where are you then moving that in the process?
Because again, I don't think it makes sense to go to acquisitions
It's also not hot, but it could be if we found them the house. It's kind of in limbo
Yeah, so, um, this person, uh, so how do I say this like, uh, they they want to sell the house
But they need a house to move into you. So
There's a couple ways to do this if it happens enough in your organization
Um, like you're getting enough leads that this comes into the equation
Um
You would build a program around this in your business like, um, this is where you'd be like, okay
Well, let me get you in contact with our, uh, agent on on staff that actually is
Um, gonna will can help you find a place would that be something to be interesting?
We help you find a place and we actually have a full service white
Uh, white love service where we help you find a place we buy your place and it's actually
Um, we do all that in the same like day essentially
So you don't you can stay inside your property all the way up until we close the next property
And it'll be one seamless transition for you including us helping you move your goods from one to the other, right?
So most people
If you have this coming up a lot like you build a program around it and you give it a nice fancy name
And it's this white, you know, white love service and that's fine, but let's just say it's like every now and again
Um, when we talk about cold warm or hot
I don't I don't like when we say that a cold lead is a cold lead because
They only want to sell in the next like six months or whatever. It's a good identifier
But it's not like the core of why we would put something as a cold lead
Cold warm or hot for me is
The the frequency in fact
I close this on my screen. Um, it's the frequency in which
Um, the person that I want to follow up with this person. So you might have somebody who
Says that they're not interested in selling and you know for six months from now
Because they're in the probate process and they're not going to sell until after probate
But we'll put them under a hot lead
Because it's in an area that we want to buy and we want to make sure that we're super attentive on that
record specifically
Um because we don't want to take the chance that you know if we put it at a cold lead, which is what they want
Um
That we miss out on being able to assist them because most likely someone else is going to call in that period in time
And so we'll put them as a warm lead
Um or a hot lead depending on the time frame here
And we'll send a text message and we'll make a phone call just let them know like hey, I'm just letting you know
I'm still here. No, no pressure
Um, but you got to be careful because some people will
This will be a deterrents like hey, just give me some breathing room
Right, um and so again, this is where the expectation of the next action is so critical where we'll say hey
Sounds great. I understand you don't want to do anything after probate's finished
We we buy a lot of probate product properties. So I just want you to know that
Um, if you have any questions on the process
I'm happy to answer it. We can give you all the details that you need
Um, what i'm going to do is i'm actually going to follow up with you at least
You know every week or two just to see how things are going and make sure that you have no problems
Um, along the process if that's okay
And so get the confirmation and now they're expected for this as a relationship and and you're they're kind of like
Buying themself into like when probate is finished. You're the one that they're going to sell to right?
It's kind of like they're they're thinking that already in their mind by saying that hey, we're going to go through this together
um
now
humans or humans and
There's been plenty of cases where we've done that and we follow up with them
We even help them solve problems
We refer our attorney to answer some side questions because there's issues and they work
They lost confidence in their attorney the very end of it probate closes and they sell to somebody else
Yeah, because we just became their friend not a buyer, right and this really
Socks when it happens, but like it does happen
But at the end of the day like we did our job by making sure the seller went from you know
Where they're at to where they became you know and that that that's all that matters
So in the case where they want to move somewhere else you could build a program around it
Or you put them in the frequency to follow up in accordance with the timelines that matters
They're not a cold lead. They could be a warm lead. We're saying hey
Just checking to see if you found a place. Can I can I send you a few recommendations?
What you may end up finding is that this person is actually a dead lead and they've been saying that for the last 10 years, you know, um, so
Yeah, all right. Thank you. Appreciate it. Yep. Awesome. Okay. Um, so
How every lead moves through a pipeline there is three stages to the pipeline
Every lead moves through these three phases either that goes from new lead unqualified and qualified
With each phase the record has a specific status task and follow-up frequency
Leads are always in motion. They promote or demo based on engagement, but they are never static
Okay, so what does this mean?
Um, well, actually we'll get into that leads in motion. It's our next section
So let's cover what the three phases are. So phase one is a new lead, right?
A brand new lead has entered the business. You call them immediately this
Phase should last one day only and that's by the end of the day
The new lead column in siff line should be empty. So if we go into my business here
We see there's three in here right now
Okay, um by the end of the day these three should be gone now. We're already at two o'clock
There's a chance that
He's moved on to some follow-up stuff, but you're supposed to prioritize new lead
So as soon as the new lead comes in you should stop your you know qualified follow-up and you should come back to this
Right. Um, so these should be empty. All right
and um
The status of this into the default build is the status becomes new lead. The task is call new lead
Their frequency is due immediately basically by 6 p.m. The same day it comes in
Um, and the duration is one day, right? So it should be done that same day
So the next morning that lead manager should be handling all overdue new leads as first thing right outside of
the very first part, which was the um, you know the
Direct mail in bounds and things like that, right?
Okay, so um the outcome of a new lead where if they answer
They you qualify and move them to cold warmer hot
If they don't answer you move them to no contact new lead
Which is phase two
Okay
Property is clearly not valuable meaning like you look at it and it's like
This is a sliver of land on an easement and the callers didn't catch that and they still considered a lead
Then you just move it the dead lead right away
right, um
They say
If they say they say no after objection handling you move them not interest
So if you get them on the phone if they answer and they say they're not interested no more
You just move them straight. They're not interested
In your business as you build out this pipeline what you're going to see is how many new leads come into your business
How many of them are unqualified qualified become dead leads and become not interested in how long does it take between that timeline to happen?
Including how long is it from the time that the record entered into my sift account to the time that even became a new lead in general?
This becomes a very clear pipeline of how many records do I need to upload and after
Uploading a hundred records over the course of the next six months. How many of those should be in what bucket?
Right, um, and this is where we build a very predictable operation. All right, so phase two
Phase two is your unqualified phase the um, which is broken down into two different frequencies
Okay
The lead has expressed interest or was identified as a potential seller from the cold collar
But you haven't spoken to them yet is two stages with different tempos
The first one is your no contact new lead. This is due daily
So no contact new lead is the property status
When I move them from new lead to no contact new lead
It changes that status automatically whether you do that from sift line or you do it from your records page
We'll cover that later. Okay
The frequency is due daily and you keep them in here for three to five days. The lead manager is the judge of this so
If after three days, you're like, you know what this isn't even really that great of a lead
It's not in one of our top neighborhoods. Yeah, there it looks like they're asking a little bit much for the property
Anyway, I'm not going to spend two more days calling this person because I'm going to have new people coming in
And so I need to move these to the next frequency
Okay
But you call every day
Double tap them ideally morning and evenings. Okay, send a text message leave voicemails
And the duration depends on the property a distressed block home from an inbound carrot lead gets five full days
So if it's a like for me if it's a block home in florida and it came from my seo website
You know like that person's gonna stay in there for five days
We're gonna call them for five days in row morning and night
Because I really want to get on a phone with them
but if it's like
A rural lot as an again. I gave the examples here for it
A rural lot with 3k comps around it like I'm not gonna keep it in there for five days and waste my lead manager's time for two extra days
They're just gonna move it to uh the weekly right
And so after they're on unqualified phase, they're gonna move or I'm sorry the the no contact newly daily
We're gonna move them to nurture new lead weekly
Okay
This is a reduced frequency. So we're taking them from
Um a daily frequency to try to get them on the phone to qualify them to a weekly frequency and the reason we do this is really important to understand
As you start generating more leads
What a lot of investors who going back to my kryptonite is they're like I got too many leads
So therefore I need to do drip campaigns
But in but what they really should be doing is they should be prioritizing which leads have less
frequency
um
And the reason why they default to drip campaigns is because they don't spend enough time educating their lead managers on how to qualify and
Teaching them all the edge cases of where are the top neighborhoods?
What are the big like how do you rack and stack these 10 leads on who's most important for us to get in contact with?
There's a very important skill set for a lead manager to know
Okay, and so instead they default like everybody just gets drip campaigns and that solves my problem
Like no it doesn't it actually means that you're gonna lose more deals
Because you're not gonna spend the right attention on the people that really matter
Okay, and so
When they're under no contact new lead daily
We're gonna if they're not somebody who
We really want to get in contact with we're gonna move them after three days because this gives me 20 more dials a day that my lead manager can do
Because they're not doing it daily here
Instead of doing it weekly
And that's really important those 20 dials means that I just opened up the ability to call the new leads that need to be called
Right, and so you just need to move them down the psych the the pipeline
In order to open up my time to focus on the ones that most matter as a lead manager. Okay, really really important
So reduce your frequency this task loops automatically just like all of them when you complete it a new one gets added
Um, and it just continues to happen. So the new lead task is added
Weekly and you just keep it under here for three to six months
Okay
So you're gonna just continue every single week to call them now. Can you move someone out of here early?
Yes, you can again if it's that lot
And for four weeks straight
You call this person day and night when the when the task becomes due and and and they're just not answering
I'm just gonna move in the dead lead. We're not gonna waste our time on something that doesn't have high opportunity
Right moving the dead lead is because it's it's not a it's not a deal that we really care enough about
But if this was a deal that was in the middle of four wall and beach
Um, it's a block home. It's distressed on the outside the land value alone is worth 120 000
Dollars, but if we rehabbed it would be worth 450 we can tear down the house and build a new house
Like yeah, i'm gonna leave it in here for six months and call it every single week
Right in fact some of those leads we just move them to hot and we just call them every two days
You know, we just we qualify them based on our desire rather than even contacting the seller
You know and so you got to be able to understand what is
The right locations what is the the the neighborhoods and the characteristics that really matter a lot to us as a company
For your lead manager to have the decision authority to make sure that they're prioritizing when he's prioritized, right?
Um, but you still need to have the core
Um process dialed in all right and so add a high value property stays there for nurture for six months
Marginal ones can be there for one to three months, right and this is going to move to ghosting
Okay
Or not interested or dead lead depending on the situation. All right, so total touches on the unqualified phase
Five daily touches plus six months is 31 total touches before it essentially goes to ghosting
I think we can all agree if somebody says i'm a new lead and you've tried to reach them 31 times and I haven't picked up the damn phone
Then they're probably ghosting you and you probably shouldn't spend more time on them
Um, you move them to ghosting and it doesn't mean they're not getting called no more
It just means that they're moving basically to a bulk monthly or you know every 45 day frequency
So we're still going to call through these people
It's just that like if they're being put into a power dialer situation or a text message situation like they're just not happening
Or this is a great place for your drip campaigns, right?
Which we're going to cover we have a ghosting drip campaign where anything that goes at ghosting gets a drip campaign
They get automatic text message they get a manual task that's added to it and this is where that lead manager
That's a cool qualifying one versus unqualified one comes into play. Okay
Important again. You are not giving up. You're just managing your time by adjusting frequency
Okay, really really important you're managing time everything that we teach at data safe is about resource resource allocation
All right, making sure that we're dialing in operations and allocating resources appropriately, which is our time and our money
All right
Arguably we do it the best
Okay, um, so
Let's see what we got in the chat real quick is this document available. Yeah, it will be it will be
All right, so leads are always in motion. Okay, so
Um, there's two different pieces of this. There's promotion in demotion. So
This is this is something a lot of again. I don't see this
Done well enough across our user base, which is why I wanted to really spend a lot more time educating lead management how to do it the right way
Okay, um
Everything promotes a cold lead will move to a warm lead a warm lead will move to a hot lead
Um, and then uh things can go from cold straight to acquisitions
Right
and um really important to know that because your frequency will increase if i'm calling a cold lead and they are somebody who
Is going through the probate process or i'm i'm manually. Let's say i call us. Let's do a different one
let's let's say i'm calling a pre foreclosure and when I first qualified them they were a
Uh cold lead. Okay, they weren't really interested. They didn't have a lot but we had like six months until you know
Like we don't have an auction date yet or anything like that. Okay, but now I go to call them again in 45 days
Which is my cold lead tempo and I they don't pick up the phone
But
I realized that an auction was scheduled for 30 days from now. What do I do?
The unsophisticated bad lead manager would leave it under cold lead
but
A good lead manager would recognize that that was the case and they would get promoted
to being a hot lead
Because i only got 30 days so i'm gonna try to get them on the phone for at least five to six days
Maybe oh two weeks, right?
And if I don't reach them then i'm gonna demote them down the warm
And they might get back demoted down to cold again
You can move someone from cold warm and hot back and forth depending on the situation and the frequency in which you need to maintain that relationship
Not just based on when the seller
um once the selder house
And another core note here very important foot stomp is it's not about when the seller wants to sell the house
It's when are you willing to go under contract and give me equitable interest in the asset
You might want to sell in six months from now
But if you sign with me today, we can start working all the time to work and everything can be perfectly ready for you
So that when you are ready to move out, we can go ahead and close
Right
So little things like that are really important to understand and change the narrative the conversation, right? We're in this together
All right
So um leads are always in motion
You have promotions and demotions right hot leads going to warm warm going to cold and cold going to hot
The reason why this is important because if you start as a cold lead that means you end
Either as
Ghosting
Or send the acquisitions or not interested right like you have these the the potential exits right which is what terminal status is is
Terminal status is like
That's the end game, you know, like that's where you go if you don't become a deal, right?
Um, it's either deadly not interested lost deal or ghosting
All right, and so you will stay in the pipeline of manual follow-up once you become a cold lead
You will stay there for basically 18 months
Okay
This is tried and true and proven
Like if you hand off
To drip campaigns and everything else. Yes, it's always bothers me like people will be like, yeah, but Tyler
I I I recaptured a deal from drip campaigns that I didn't pick up the phone like yeah, I you're going to
You're gonna recapture deals, but you know what you can't quantify how many deals you lost by not doing manual follow-up
Like yeah, it's easy to be like oh, yeah, this person responded to the drip campaign
And so therefore you recapture the lead because of drip campaigns
But let's look at how many lost deals you have
Across the board
Like the only way to know how many deals you would have got if you actually do manual follow-up and nurture the leads as you're supposed to
When you spend a ton of marketing dollars to generate the leads
Is to actually just do the job you're still gonna lose deals sure
But like having a really dedicated lead manager is by far the most important thing ever
Okay
And extending out 18 months has been the biggest result for us to make sure that we convert
Those people who were on the fence those absentee owners that are seniors that
weren't really ready yet because this was their rental property and they had a tenant in there for example
Right like 18 months is the target
I've made the most amount of money on deals between 12 and 18 months of follow-up
Okay
So
Terminal statuses these are the exit points from the active pipeline
So no matter where they're at in the qualified or unqualified process
These are the the exit points. So a dead lead
Clearly never going to be a deal unrealistic expectations property not viable or outbound team pushed it
But after reviewing it automatically not viable no task added
Handled through marketing filters right so dead leads like it goes back to marketing basically
It's pretty much it okay
Not interested you spoke to the seller they explicitly say they're not they don't want to sell
You went through your objection list and they confirmed this is not
We couldn't so this is not that we couldn't reach them
It's that they weren't interested in selling right it
This requires a conversation to happen to say that they're not interested right
Lost deals is at any point the property got listed with an agent or sold to another investor
The deal is gone. No task is added moved to lost deal phase and siff line
If you move it's a lost deal phase and siff line it just
You know, it'll it'll
Up the default bill does this but in my account
I have it updated where if you move it to the lost deal pipeline any of these exit statuses
It removes it from the board. I don't remember if the default builds updated with that
We might have added that after we release the default bill that might need updated okay
Um
Which is fine. You can leave it in there. There's no problem with that
Um, I just like clearing it out because we have filters in our records page that catches it
Okay
Ghosting is the most prominent that's gonna happen between ghosting and lost deals with me the two things that happen the most okay
The leads stopped communicating over time. There's no active tasks. That's added to this record
Um, but they receive periodic marketing campaigns every 45 to 90 days
Ghosting is not permanent if they respond they re enter into the qualified phase
Right and so if a ghosting you're gonna have kpi's you start building where how many ghosting lead dials happen before they reconvert back to being a new lead again
Right and they enter back on the cycle
Same thing with not interested. They have the same thing that happened right
Most users are familiar with not interested campaigns because of marketing
They don't think about not interested campaigns when it comes to their lead management, right?
And they're really two separate things
You could wrap them all into one marketing cycle, but the most important is not interested that are leads if you're not calling not interested
People that said they're a lead and then said not interested are the most important not interested to call okay
All right, and then the last
um
Motion that can happen to a lead is the hand off the acquisitions right when a qualified lead is ready for an offer
Move it to the send the acquisitions phase on the lead management sipline board
This triggers the sequence that creates a make offer tasks and moves the card to the acquisitions board if the lead comes back
It enters to the send back the lead management phase and re enters your workflow
Usually at warm or hot since they're recently engaged through
Uh enough to warn an offer. So what this means is that underneath the acquisitions board
Okay
Um, there is a send back to lead management if we're not covering acquisitions today
We're covering lead management
but
under acquisitions
If if they're not if they're going to get back like they were ejected an offer or we've done follow up and it's not whatever
Um, you move it to send back a lead management which kicks it back to lead management board
And for us, it's under needs review
Um for you guys. I can't quite remember the the the phase, but there is a phase. Okay
And uh, we have a ton here because we had a ton under acquisitions that bottle necked up with offers that
Um needed to be handled over the last like six months. So, um
Uh, this should be empty essentially at the end of every day. Um, there's a filter for that which i'll show later, right?
But what happens here is this is that that process where the acquisitions person
You know, uh said, hey, this person needs to go back to nurture because acquisitions people should not be doing long-term follow up
That's what a lead manager is for. Um, and if we're finding a bottleneck there, there is an operational issue either i'm bad qualifying
Uh lead manager sending the wrong people to get offers
Uh, or your initial pipeline is just sending stuff that isn't really that great, right?
Um
acquisitions to be spending all their time
Uh making offers and also some people are like, well, I got too many things that need offers
So therefore I need an acquisitions person
But it might just be that you don't need an acquisitions person your lead manager should be better qualifying
And you could literally sit be the acquisitions person and making the two offers a day
Um, the two to five offers a day and this in itself would save you 20
Net margins at the end of every single year and you can put way more money in your pocket, right?
It really depends on the organization that you're growing but just keeps it in the back of your mind
Um, with a better lead manager means that you can sit with an acquisition role a lot longer
But anyway, okay
So what is the daily flow? What do we add on time?
I was doing what I'm not doing too bad a lot of information
So uh, you guys probably gonna have to regurgitate this a couple times potentially
um, but
What is the daily workflow of a lead manager? Okay, um, we're gonna work through these in order every day
So the first thing is oh, yeah, one rule over over rules everything a new inbound lead or a newly submitted lead
Um takes immediate priority over whatever you're currently doing and working on
Okay, really important. Um, and if you guys notice like this is a training manual for your lead manager
If you have your lead manager just go through and read through this
like
And watch this training like they should be able to become really amazing or you need to fire them because like this is
Probably the most in-depth lead management management training that I've that probably I don't know
Maybe there's more in-depth one out there that'll exist, but I I'm gonna probably think not
Um, so clear the queue. That's the very first instance of porn
So any missed calls voicemails text messages from the previous day you got to clear the queue
If you don't clear the queue you get more behind and then this compounds really quickly and then you live in
Chaos, okay
Have it to clear the queue for the first hour of the day or however it needs to be you clear the queue
Okay, so you're checking for inbound from direct mail. You're checking your smartphone in our case inbound leads folder
Your ppl ppl leads from property leads and smartphone your ppl folders
Um, uh, your carrot leads carrot leads and smartphone in online inbounds, right?
So in smartphone we have a folder for in online inbounds where all the inbound phone calls from our website
Or seo files everything goes to a folder communications inbox called online inbounds
Ppl leads go to ppl inbounds and um, any of our direct mail goes to inbound leads, right?
And so those those three different folders and so what the va does is they
J check each of those phone numbers
Was there any missed phone calls and then they check the folders themselves to see if anybody responded previous text messages
And then they go into their call new lead task preset, which is preset zero inside of um
Our accounts i'm not going to be able to see this because I can't see it right now. Okay, so
Um, you can see we have call new lead tasks that pairs with call new lead tasks
So if I go in there right now and I select that one
Um and do do today you can see I have two tasks that are due so those need to be completed
Right. Um, and then you also check overdue you do overdue first and then do today. Okay
Right now
Overdue we got none fantastic. Right and so we have two new uh lead tasks
Okay
So that's the first thing they do after they clear their queue they check do I have any new lead tasks
Brand new leads needing first attempt complete the same day new lead column should be empty by the end of every day
Again within this training and you're you're literally in this how to do your day flow
You're i'm telling your lead managers like that is the expectation
Okay
All right. So once you make sure everything is empty there
If no new leads came in for you to call right now, you're moving to your unqualified lead task follow
This is the no contact new lead daily follow-up and nurture new lead weekly call double tap text voicemails
So what am I going to do? I'm going to go into my filters
And of course you could do this as a quick filter, but i'm not
Um, I don't have that on my on my my login here. Um, so I would do unqualified lead tasks
So is looking for anything that's no contact new lead
like apply
I have one that's great. Do I have any that are overdue?
Only four right? So that's good. I mean for how many leads we have in our system like that's fantastic
You know, um, that means my lead managers doing their job and they're keeping up with things
Okay, and so the next thing
Um, qualify lead follow-up. This is hot leads that are due every two days warm leads are due every 15 days coldies every 45 days
Work overdue first then do today. So let's go look at those. This is the one that you know could be a lot more in there
So let's see
So lead manager, uh, qualify lead tasks. We got cold warm and hot statuses and we're going to do overdue first
This one's a hard one to keep up with. We got 11. Okay, so that's not bad, right? We got a bunch of warm leads cold leads hot leads here
And then we have due today
We got one. So this is great. So we got some overdoers to do
He's been prioritizing the new stuff and and um, he's got some overdue as a catch-up one
Okay, um, and then leads missing tasks. This is a daily safety net
Any lead without a task is invisible to your workflows
Okay, I I cannot stress how our system allows you to do this better than many systems out there
Because we started with data management like managing leads without tasks for like
50 leads or something like this is like so dang simple for us. Um, it should be zero every day
Um
It's literally in your default builds. So there's zero reason not to click on this filter
Um, let's see how many we may have
Uh, right now. So it's leads missing tasks is looking at your cold lead warm lead hot lead and then no contact new leads
Okay, with zero tasks on it
Hopefully we only have a few there we go. We got a few so what would cause this right?
Um, this happens
Why it happens is because of a human brain
Can anybody guess what did we say earlier that it's supposed to stop this from happening
Tab them exactly
So the reason why stab them doesn't work right sometimes is because people get in the daily rut of the business
That's why you need to have fail safes and you need some of the QC. I don't care what it is
I don't care if you're a billion dollar company
Right like you have quality assurance people that is why they exist because we understand humans are humans
And that's why ai is trying to take over humans freaking jobs
Robots right because robots don't forget to do stab them
Right, but robots also are creepy and don't have personalities. So therefore we still need lead managers
All right, um, not to say that we can't offload some of the
Mutein tasks like colds to like maybe like a lead manager ai agent and things like that
But we need we need good people okay
We need to run our companies off of people still for the core jobs and use ai to bolster them as people
Okay, so we have this filter to catch that
Why else does this happen is because there's another person in the company that sends something back to lead management the wrong way
Meaning like an acquisition person doesn't move it to send back the lead management, but instead they have a doofy moment
You know and they they just move it directly to their board and change the status
But they don't move it where it belongs
So therefore it never gets the task like the sequences the automations never ran
I don't care what system you go to this will be a problem
If your people don't do what they're supposed to do and move the stuff where it's supposed to go
It's not going to work the way it's expected
The only most important thing is to make sure that you have a process baked into your organization to qc
On a regular basis to make sure things go as they're supposed to go
That is how you win
That is what makes the difference between an actual business and somebody who's just
Getting lucky
right
All right
So send back to lead management preset and you're going to notice this is the one that we're going to have a lot on here in our account
And so we're going to look at our lead management send back to lead management tasks
And i'm going to remove me here and we're going to look at overdo is going to be ton
151 of them right
You see they have a bunch of different statuses and stuff like that. These all need reviewed and put on where they belong
Inside of the sales cycle because they were sitting underneath the acquisitions board for way too long
and
again, it was a situation where
The acquisitions was treating themselves as a lead manager rather than a lead manager being you know, the the the priority, okay
So
After we go through this, this is our daily flow the end of day checklist before you log off
Check for miss calls voicemails and texts that need to be responded to
Confirm new leads phase is empty
Confirm all tasks due today are completed or rescheduled and then transfer your tally count numbers to the kpi gucci
Okay, common mistakes leaving new leads overnight
skipping the leads missing task filter
Batching kpi entry at the end of the week rather than daily and then forgetting to log your call notes on
records
Okay
It's probably the most important part of this whole thing for your actual team members
But that everything above that kind of stages what needs to be addressed
at a time, okay
All right, um, so now we're at the point where we know exactly
Um, you know what needs to be done and what a lead manager is and what phases leads go in and we haven't even got into like
moving a record through sift in this way
Um, but um, this is the foundational knowledge that none of it matters if we don't understand these core concepts of of what leads are
What phases leads go through and what the responsibilities of a lead manager are
Um, the default build is very clear to say like if you update a status to new lead
It's going to automatically put it into this sequence and as long as you do these
Check these filters. You're going to succeed, right?
Um
So we're going to transition to now is custom lead fields and the intake call
So when you get that first call coming in so there's seven custom field folders that um, I like, okay
qualifying questions
property condition
Cap X assessment, I like cap X being separate than the property condition
Okay, because um, it's the biggest expense on the flip
It is the question on if cap Xs are good
A property can sell on the MLS
Right, so it's really important difference between condition there versus the other now is there overlap there?
Yeah, sure there is right property debts
So as much information we can get from the seller for the mortgage
How much the mortgage is if there's any taxes leans h a ways, uh, is it going through probate right now?
Is there a foreclosure going on?
This types of information is very very useful and we can use that again to our benefit
Title and ownership. This is like who is actually has the authority here?
Is it in the trust? Is there multiple errors? Who are those errors? Is there attorney involved right now?
Um, if you're not going to take, uh, if you're not talking to the decision maker, you're wasting your time
right, um
And then deal intelligence. So this is what price, um, are they getting their information from?
Um, a lot of people they they don't ask this question, but the sellers will tell it to them
Enough where they're like, well, Zillow says that it's worth $300,000
Right and so, um, this is where that comes in. So what is the seller's price coming from?
Is it Zillow?
Did they get an agent appraisal?
Is it just in their own head because if it's in their own head and the lead manager says that now the acquisitions person can use that
And they already have the information to be able to change the way that they sell
So if the lead manager says like their price is coming out of their head, this is what they thought it was worth
Right then that means that the acquisitions person it says like so I see that you feel like the property is worth this
Right and so they can change where their verbiage is
Okay, so are they open to creative terms all that information lives there and then appointment in next steps
This is like do we have photos already?
Um, this this is really we get into like the tc kind of, um process
Right, do we have a lockbox code? Um, do we do an appointment to go get photos that kind of stuff? Okay, um, the big thing here is
These should be updated real time as much as possible. So update custom fields dawning or immediately after the seller conversation
Do not leave for acquisitions to discover later
The acquisitions people should not be having to pull this information out
Acquisitions should be focused on sales tactics and and and and not
Um gathering information, right? They should have the information at their disposal so that they can use the sale taxes
For example, if you have a hostage negotiator, right? What does the hostage negotiator do before he starts talking to the person that has the hostage
He learns as much about that person as possible. He finds out that they have kids
They have this that everything they can because it changes the way that they communicate
To pull out the emotion. Okay, really really important
Um, and so the fields
You uh, the fields are your intake guide refer to the custom field md file again
You guys are going to get the folder if you want to update and add more to it
Um, the md file for your complete
Field by field breakdown
Um, and the capx cheat sheet. Okay, within that md file. There's a cheat sheet on why the um
Why the capx is matter
So if we ask clawed right now
Um, for example, can you tell me why?
Capx matters to a lead manager
And we'll let it look through that
and tell us
um
When we bring a eye into the organization and we have our lead manager have access to this folder
They can ask questions and make sure they're setting things up right or whatever and and some more qualifying
And you as a as a manager can update and add your own md file for you unique situations on different things, right? Let's see how well it did
Okay, so capx matters to lead manager for one reason it directly
Controls the offer number right here's the chain lead manager captures capx
Um on the seller roof age whatever underwriter uses the capx pick to rehab scenarios
cosmetic medium or full gut rehab scenarios set the max allowable offer
Uh full gut pulls 55 blah blah blah blah, right? This is all piping into our underwriting process
Okay, um it so it matters because if you don't put your capx is on here and we don't fill that information out on custom fields
You're directly affecting the speed in which we can produce offers
Okay
All right, so qc
We're getting close to the in here folks, uh, we're actually making pretty damn good time
I'm pretty happy about that. All right. So qc is a daily discipline not an occasional audit
For example, the stab them handles real-time quality control, right?
But it is a proactive whereas the actual qc
Is reactive
Right when I go in there and I click on the qc filters that I have in my account
I am being reactive
I'm doing a reactive effect to make sure that my team was being proactive
Right and so the four audit filters below are your weekly safety net
They catch anything that slipped to the cracks
These filters are not built out in your default build
This is a great example of one of those things where as you get used to just a general flow of things
You can add these things to your business, right?
So filter one is a task check
What this is doing is looking at our board task check
So it finds records on boards in phases that have overdue tasks and do tasks
Look for overdue tasks that haven't been addressed
conflicting tasks and make offer tasks or a no contact new record task
Or records move between phases without sequences updating
Sometimes sequences fail, right?
It's technology it happens, right?
When I move someone one phase something book bottleneck doesn't happen
So we got to catch that and so the number one qc problem is the status versus phase Mitch match, okay?
The single most frequent qc issue is records
Where the status doesn't match the board phase example a record in the cold lead phase
But is a not interested status this happens when someone changes the status manually instead of just moving it to the phase
It belongs to trigger the automation
All right
And so for example tasks check
By the way, this this is the same thing every time so you have task check this this this right so your task check is checking
Um
To make sure that the stab them that all records have a task, okay
I'll do these filters in a check second just to check my my team might as well over here, right?
So filter to no tasks at all
Filters records on a board that have zero tasks a record
Um on the board with no tasks invisible
So the first one is that there's multiple tasks, right or or overdue
And then the next one is that there's no tasks at all and then double tasks and then missing phone numbers
Okay, so let's just go ahead and just do this inside of
Um my account real quick
So I have these because it's the predominant thing that I do
I have these as quick filters for me. Okay, so i'm going to click on boards task check
And i'm just going to open up my filter records and i'm going to show you it's looking at the lead management phase
With any phase
Okay, so it's a lead management board on any phase in the tasks or overdue
You can see that currently we have 280 and we know that predominantly pretty much all of those are
um that phase with the um status, so what I can do is I can just check that and say, okay, let me go to the
um
The needs review phase and see how many of those are from that
Okay, 153 of them, right and so I know that that's a problem
All right, and then I look at some of these other ones and I look at let's just say our cold lead phase
It's probably a bunch on 119. So what's causing that?
Well, this is a cold lead phase where we we have a bunch of stuff
We're still cleaning up underneath our board like so we know this is an apparent thing on our coldy board. So we have 480 under here
Okay, uh really there should only be
Right around like 200 or so
Okay, um because there's a lot of that that we lost deals on and we needed a lot of cleanup
Right because there is a lapse of uh
bad
Lead management activity. Let's just say um and so
Um, so these qc's will catch that right. Um, so the question is do you know it exists or do you not know it exists number one?
All right, so the next thing is um boards with no tasks check at all
So if I felt about it's looking at the lead management phase where there's no tasks on anything
And so we can see which ones are there so not interested not interested sold sold listed
Okay, those aren't supposed to have tasks on them, but they're also not supposed to be on this board
Right and so the lead matter needs come in here or what I would do is I come in here
And I would say okay. Well, I look at what's going on. I look at the date and the time
And then I'll just move this it's under the needs review, right? So, okay. Okay. Well, if it's sold already
It doesn't need needs reviewed it needs moved to it just needs moved right
Um, we're just gonna move that to lost deal boom done
And so I would clean those up and just make sure that they're not gonna stay under here and we just clean up the board, right?
Okay, um, the next one is going to be boards with two more tasks
So this is looking at is anything on the lead management phase have two tasks on it
Because that shouldn't be the case like this lead right here has two tasks. Why is why is a new lead have two tasks on it?
All right, so you stab the record, right? We see it came back from acquisitions or probably has a
No contact new lead and a new lead task on it
And I could look at my activity log and figure out why that happened, right?
Again, q seeing it says keep it here maddy is going to deep dive it and so they're doing something with this they understand what's going on
This is literally from today
but
It's underneath of the new lead phase
Um, and they're deep diving to try to get in contact with another relative right now. That's what they're doing. Okay, so
Should it have both these tasks on it? No, it should probably have no tasks on it or some other random tasks right now, honestly
Okay, and so again you go through that and then you have your boards missing a correct number. This is a pretty big one
Um
Does it does something on the lead management phase not have a correct number at all? You'll see that for the most part
Um, most of these are going to be old stuff. That's like listed or not listed
We got 13 on here, but like these ones that are cold leads right here
Um, why do we not have one there?
It's because the caller messed up or someone messed up and changed the no answer here
So we got to go back and make sure that we mark this as a primary number because this happens all the time where something
You know breaks and and and somebody changes something and it shouldn't be that and you know as a product
Solution here. We're going to make it to where if it's a cold lead or a lead we lock phone number or statuses for primaries or whatever
But um, there has to be an override basically what happens, but nonetheless
Um until then, you know
It's important to make sure you have your qc process dialed in okay
All right, so kpi tracking
You your numbers tell a story, right?
We track kpi's manually. We use tally counter and google sheets on purpose
There is no way to get closer to perfect than to do it yourself
In real time rather than relying on any crm to tell you this information right now
um
Will you be able to through our open api and cloth and our dashboards to know at a high level like hey?
This is how many you know what the flow looks like and what our high level is like sure
Right, but to really dial into the amount of dials that were made and the edge cases and all these different things
Tracking it manually is by far your most effective thing
Right and the amount of dials that somebody makes a day as a lead manager to not be able to track their kpi's through tally count
To me
Um, if they can't do that then it's like they're just not the performer you want in your business
Right, it's not fun. I'm not saying that it is right, but it's the job right
Um, and I don't want people that are like
Not wanting to do the job and they just want things to be easy, you know every single second of the day, right?
It's not that difficult to do that
Um
And so we try giving you the tally count and these were some baseline metric
Baseline metrics that I would consider for you guys to put for your lead managers right or for any lead manager right 150 dials minimum daily
Um, this is the floor not the target. It means that you should be maintaining and at least getting 150 dials out there
Um, and in in like that should
It should be pretty easy to do like our callers make more than that in their you know prospecting and so to do that from a record
It should be there
now
If you have at least 25 conversations in a day does that mean that you need to hit 150 dials
Probably not right um, you could end up having 25 conversations. They're great conversations and so therefore you're not going to hit that minimum
So you can't just look at this are like, oh, well, hey, they're not hitting 150 dials
Right, but they should have the ambition to dial through 150 because if you dial through 150 you have, you know
Just do the the contact right there, right?
25 divided by 150 is a 16 pick up rate conversation that's happening right and that's pretty realistic
Right, you know 150 dials, you know, you might only talk to one to one, you know with 20 25 people, right?
So that conversation rates between 15 and 20 percent, all right
If you get above that then fantastic that means that your leads have nothing to do
But sit there and answer the phone all day like that's a great problem that
Um, but is it realistic with people to have jobs depending on the avatars and stuff like that?
No, not necessarily, right?
So, um, you should be able to send if you're having 25 conversations a day you should be sending two to five people to
Uh to have an offer made, okay, um, that's the money metric, right? That's the one that you need to know
You need to know how many how many uh
New leads need sent to acquisitions to create an offer, right?
Um, and then same day contact means that
If a new lead came in today, I've attempted it today
Um, you that's the benchmark is a hundred percent
Uh, the chances that is probably if you're generating say 10 leads a day, um, you're probably going to be at 80 percent
Right, but we don't want to say like, oh, yeah, you're okay with only dialing, you know
Eight of the 10 lead new leads that come today
We want to be able to say you need to dial every new lead that comes in today
But the reality is that they're done at five or six o'clock at night and new leads come in in the evening
And so therefore it's not going to be a hundred percent. Okay, um leads missing tasks. However, you know, should be zero
Um, that's preset three check we should check it every day and ideally it's zero
Um, the reality is you're going to have a few right so it's not like we're being like super sticklers here
We're just saying hey, this is the standard, um, and we aim to be
Perfect, um, but we're not we're not expecting that we're going to be that every single day. Okay
All right, um, the daily, uh tracking process right so tally count
to
Uh, at the end of the day open the fce re kpi google sheet lee manager tab add a new row transfer your tally count number is one
To one in those columns pretty simple. Okay, uh verify cross reference data sift for pipeline metrics conversions
Should never exceed dials
Send to acquisition should be traceable to records you moved right?
Um, do not batch this on a weekly basis. All right
Cool drip campaigns
Um drip campaigns
Automate follow-up on records that are no longer need manual
Effort right the primary use case is leads that have exited the active pipeline
Ghosting and not interested leads where you still want
Periodic contact without burning calling hours right again maintaining our resources
Um drips, uh supplement your manual workflow. They do not replace it
Um, your daily workflow meaning your filter presets your manual task loops
Um
Handles active leads drip campaigns pick up on the manual effort where it leaves off right?
Um, so for example, I have an I have an example sequence here for ghosting nurture
Um ghosting lead nurture 45 days
Four cycles so it's a total of 142 days and it triggers when a record moves to the ghosting lead phase
So if you want to update this all you have to do is go into your sequences
And then find where that moves to so this would be under lead management and it would be um move
Uh to ghosting let me find it here right here clear ghosting actually it's clear ghosting enter into it
And click make changes
Add new action and then you're going to go down to run drip campaign drag that over
And then if you've created that ghosting lead nurture campaign you select it and now anytime a lead enters into that phase
It's going to add that ghosting lead nurture in there. Okay
And then within your drip campaigns underneath of your ghosting lead nurture
You can build that out
As i've said inside of there
And what you'll notice is that I have a ghosting lead follow-up task in here
Um, and so there if you're going to do this you're going to want to task new fault new filter right that's looking for
ghosting lead follow-up and if you add this again, you would want to add that to your daily workflow
Where that's probably the last thing that they do before they check if leads are missing tasks
Right they're going to check any tasks for ghosting lead follow-up
All right, and over time this would end up being assigned to a different lead manager than your qualifying manager
Right, you'd have somebody else that does the
Qualification follow-up and this would be only for those the person that's doing the initial
Uh, new lead conversations because they're going to have more time than the person that has like 600
leads compared to the person that has like 40 that they're maintaining at any given moment, right
And so uh again that flow is
You got some cycles here one cycle two cycle three cycle four
um every 45 days
Um, and you can you can throw in some text messages in there
Based on whatever you really want to do here again mine
You can see at the top send text message created tasks and sms created tasks and sms created tasks
send sms created tasks goes out 142 days, okay
You also need to be integrated with you know something that has
Um the ability to send text messages. I'm smartphone, you know, you can integrate with Twilio
You know, you can do kicks. Uh, actually kicks you can send a Twilio and smartphone. I think other too
You can send text measures one
Um Twilio is easy enough to get uh connected on
But if you have smartphone you can do that and hopefully soon we can get kicks the added and some other options
Um, the other big thing with trip campaigns is you're sent to
You need to go through all your ghosting leads beforehand and make sure that they have primary numbers on them
Right, so that means that on the record itself inside of a record
um
You know, you want to make sure that that phone number is set the primary because if you have like six different correct numbers on here
Either going to text six people at one time or just the one that's the primary and ideally it's the primary
It's going to give you the best tendi. You'll see a two p and whatnot protection
Also, don't add like a thousand ghostings all at one time
If you're want to backfill this then filter by your ghosting leads add 10 then add another 10 then add another 10
You know and just do it like over the next 30 days add
Like five or 10 to it depending on how many you have so that you don't just like send
A thousand at once and mess up your phone number
And more importantly, you don't have a thousand tasks do in seven days to call a ghosting lead
Right like uh trickle it in there a lot of people get over zealous and like well, I'm just gonna do all this now
It's like okay. Well, it's not gonna
Let's focus on your top a funnel pipeline. That's the most important thing. Okay
Okay, the next one is gonna be you're not interested nurture
Make a 14 day buffer from the time that it became not interested and then you know, send your first text message
Four cycles 360 days
Um, I I honestly prefer manual here
Um, but it's totally preference at the end of the day you guys do what you want to do here
but um
Uh, I care more about that initial funnel not the things that are leaving and the ghosting leads not interested right now
Like if you can get the new lead and in the other funnel to where when
If you get the new lead to send acquisitions pipeline and all that stuff out and everything we've covered so far
You're going to be successful. Um, this is just a
Close the loop and really dig in deeper, but I would say for most of you, it's gonna be six months until you really you can truly
um
uh, focus on ghosting and not interested nurtures for
leads and instead
I would just throw these into a dialer once a month or every two months and just call through the whole thing or text through the whole thing
And just try to re-engage them, right?
Um, some critical rules, um drips run on autopilot. So once they're enrolled they fire no matter what whether you add other
Or not. So if say say like a drip your ads added to a drip campaign
But then it becomes a new lead again make sure you turn like turn off the drip campaign from that record
Uh, because otherwise it's gonna create another task that's gonna send another text message
Um, because you're you're accepting the responsibility of i'm adding something through a drip campaign
Um, so just make sure that your lead manager removes it if in fact, you know, this person does convert to being a new lead again
Um
Sequence based removal so you can remove these I actually, um, don't know that sequences has the ability to remove
I don't think we've released that so this is in here because I
I thought we had it and I thought we had it set up and we didn't
Yeah, I'm sure this is gonna create some
Some questions, but uh, that's the ideal scenario when it moves back to being in a new lead if something gets added to the new lead board
It it removes it from any drip campaigns. So
Um, but then also no task conflicts drip campaigns for leads that exited, um, the active task pipeline
Uh, be careful not to have
You know, um
a record underneath two different drip campaigns and
You know, like you're getting a same task due on two days in a row or you know, whatever, right?
Just be careful
Um drip campaigns create a lot of noise a lot of chaos and that's why i'm really fond of
You know, uh, a very systematic operational approach on that that uh top of funnel
At the bottom down here, I have different lume videos on how to process carrot leads inside your account ppl leads
Um, these are leads from my from my business and you can, um, watch those lume videos and and see how we do those
Um, you know from going to
One place to another place and updating it within sift
This is probably the biggest thing that will change because as we release new product features like our
You know inbox for example, uh, when that releases the communications inbox like these won't these will change on how we do this
Right? So just keep that in mind
And then some final keys to success. Okay
Are in here as well. Uh, what time we at man? We're we're getting pretty close here. So, um
What I want to do now as I just want to show some examples of the custom fields
and i'm going to um
Login to uh, I don't know if I want to do it in this account because my team's in here
Um, but uh, let's at least look at the custom fields and let's kind of explore what that looks like
Um, and i'm just going to kind of walk through i'm not going to click it through
I'm just going to kind of generally
Go through the new lead sequence and the kind of default build on how this record will flow through it
I'm not going to actually do the clicks, but i'm going to explain how it would go and i'm going to pretend i'm doing the clicks
okay, so
uh first and foremost, let's just go to
um, somebody who
Let's say it's not interested in they converted to being a new lead, right?
Um, what does that custom field look like and what is my lead manager doing under those custom fields? So, um
I don't have my one like this sorts and I don't have it sorted right now, but
Um, first and foremost is qualifying questions, right? So i'm going to ask the qualifying questions
Um, now your collars can fill this into if your collars are doing first of market and they're within the system
They can ask these questions. So like timeline to sell
Um, choose the the timeline, right?
Um reason for selling I have a bunch of different reasonings in here for a job relocation tired landlord inherited divorce financial hardship
Um, estate or probate behind on payments pre foreclosures kind of the same thing a little different
Um, and then other right and so select whichever that reasoning is
Um, and then go through and these are qualifying questions kind of like our understanding the motivation of the seller, okay?
Um, have they received offers from somebody else?
Um, yes or no if they did receive an offer from somebody else, how much was that offer?
Um, is the price flexible, right? Are you open to negotiations on that price?
Uh, was it previously listed with an agent?
A question that we should ask sellers a lot of people don't ask that question and then they go to get on our contract and turn
It's out it was listed like two weeks ago in the seller the agent has a uh, uh, clouded title on it
Um, which is a thing in case you guys didn't know that
Uh, what happens after they sell another really massively missed opportunity in a question to ask
I cannot count how many times we've had it where my team
Didn't ask this question. They didn't properly do this all the way through acquisitions
We're about to close on the deal and the person wants to stay there for three months
How how does that happen? You know, uh, we should know that way ahead of time
Um, and so again, we should be asking that ahead of time. What do you what is your plans?
Especially for the elderly we need to make sure they have a place to go and you make sure they're taking care of and we can't just
Push them out of their homes
Um, in whatnot. So again qualifying questions
The next thing is going to be property condition general
So this is really where the lead manager comes in a lot to gather this information
Your, um, your callers will also gather this but like overall condition if we can get anything
Literally ask the seller this because you're trying to gauge what they think the properties work
Right. So it's like, okay, great. Um, now i'm curious if if you were to tell me, um, at a high level here
Um, would you consider the property as moving ready?
Um, needing some minor cosmetics or does it need, you know, generally like a full updating or significant, you know, work
like is there like, you know, um
You know drywall repairs, you know, holes and things like that or you know, is it like in pretty big distress
You know, which category would you put it in like literally likes from their words?
Let, you know, know what it is and you might update that after you finish the rest of these questions because you might say, okay
Well, um, go ahead and tell me a little bit about the interior
Condition right and then I write down my interior condition. Okay. Tell me a little bit about the exterior condition
You know, what's the roof like and you know the paint and things like that
Vacancy status is it occupied is it not occupied people rush through these questions
And then it really bites you in the butt and you finally get the contract out there and you and you get surprises
Um, so is there a tenant in there? Is there a lease?
Um, is there drunk or debris at the house because again, if there's junk at the house and it's significant
You'll they'll say like oh, they were a hoarder. Yeah, my parents. They were a really big hoarder
Like it's in extreme condition. That's a big thing because again, if there's a lot of junk in the house
Who here's done flips? How much does it cost to remove junk nowadays?
All business model like tick-tock famous kind of stuff, you know, like you charge $5,000 to get junk out of the house
You know, um, so it's crazy, you know, so uh, it is very expensive and so we need to know that that if that's the case
Um, is there any soft floors or water damage?
Um, is there any prior flooding or mold if you're in an area like florida? This happens a ton
Um
One was the last year that there was any major updates
Right
And then any photos obtained like do because sometimes you can get photos of these things right away
Hey, can you just send me a photo that wire on the call and you can they can do that, right?
All right, capex assessment, um, is the next thing so all right great. Well, I really appreciate all that information
I'm just gonna ask a few questions about the capex. Um, this is like the big items on the house
And you we've already discussed some of it. So we're gonna be pretty quick here
But just to confirm because again, they might already have told you this
But you want to double it because you want to catch them in a frick up
Okay, uh, because they'll tell you it's great. But then when you go a little bit deeper, they'll tell you it's not
Okay, and so like capex assessment, um, roof condition and so okay
And what now would you say that the roof is currently insurable or does it need replacement?
Um, was it recently updated?
Um, and look like I can ask like that. Would you would you say the roof is insurable or do you think it needs replacement or
Uh, was it recently updated? So I'd literally ask the three questions in a phrase
Um, and I say it's probably insurable and I'm like, okay, cool. So it's insurable. Um, how how old is the roof?
What year was it replaced?
I'm gonna say like, oh, well, like maybe like 18 years ago. I'm like, okay. Well, actually
Sadly roofs roofs require like at least within the last 15 years. So it's actually probably going to need replaced
So, um, if you were to try to list this right now, for example, insurance would not approve that
Right. And so we're going to now break down the seller a little bit on the expectations that they're thinking
Right. And so we're going to say, okay, it needs replacement. Um, and then we're going to put 18 years
Okay. And the same thing is through the HVAC HVAC years any notes about the roof, right?
Is there is there any leaks? Yeah, uh, it needs replaced. There's some leaks in the one bedroom
Right. Um, we'll put that in place. But why because that's information and they're like, hey, you're saying there's leaks in there. Um, is there
That's that mean there's mold because above you said there was no mold
Now you're saying there is mold or the mold question might have surfaced like oh, yeah, the roof needs replaced because there ain't no roof
There's no leaks if there isn't a roof
You know, um, uh, that has leaks right or there's no mold if there isn't a roof that has leaks
Um, and so on so we're going to ask those and then again, um, electrical notes and junk removal needed again. Um, if the junk removals needed
We're just adding this here even though it's up here, right? We're adding it down there
Uh, because we're asking the seller here. This isn't a question to the seller. This is us saying yes or no
So that we can have this information here, um, for the, uh, um, underwriting, okay
Um, okay, so the next thing i'm going to do is i'm going to have property debt and in conversations
Okay, and uh, we actually typically present like a few different offers to the seller
Um, and to do that we we typically understand like what is currently going on with the mortgage like do you happen to know the mortgage balance right now?
What's the status of the mortgage, right? Is it is it current? Is it behind at all? You don't have a mortgage?
Um, back code taxes h away, um, code violation leans that you're aware of any unpermitted work
Um, any probate situations is foreclosure been filed and any other encumbrance notes like the situation around that that might be pertinent to us, right?
Um, title ownership
Once we get through all that now we're going to ask because we get as much sauce as we can from them and then we're going to say hey
Um, are you the owner of record? Are you the one that currently owns property in this case?
Maybe no, there might be partial owner. So it might be multiple people on title. Um, any other heirs
associated
Okay, yes, no unknown if we do have other heirs we can enter the heirs names here
Okay, and then um, so on and so forth, right? And then the the part that's uh for acquisitions predominantly is going to be the deal intelligence, right?
Um, so sellers price expectations and the source
Um, so you're going to say whether it's from Zillow Redfin an agent told them my favorite
Um, neighborhood sold for my second favorite
Um, whether it's an emotional decision just a random number which is basically the same as emotional a little different
Um
And then uh, seller open to below market offer
And so on right cash or or you know, if if you could get a cash offer would that be okay?
Or would be open to financing it, right? And so we answer those questions and then how did you hear about us?
Uh, questions are one that honestly a lot of people just never ask whatsoever
Uh, and it can honestly tell you a lot of information
Now if you know that we just spoke to them on the phone
Just put that it came from a cool call campaign
Uh, if you're unsure because it was inbound then ask the question, right?
Um, it can tell you a lot of information, right? And then deal intelligence notes. This would be anything that would help, you know
Us make an offer it has my name in here, right?
But uh, seller's emotional state what they care about the most
Um, all that good stuff because we can use that for rapport. Okay, and for our, uh, acquisitions
Okay, the last folder here is going to be your appointments next steps. So is photos on file?
This is really a tc and acquisitions kind of, um, uh, folder here, but, um, yes, they're uploaded to the record
So we have a, uh, whether it's a folder link or whatever
Um, you can put it there
I don't have it here, but you could add a
Um, a place right here for a url if you, you know, share it from a folder, um, like in texture email or uploads the record
Um, you could update that if you want and then, um, field visit scheduled
Um, so if it's been scheduled to go check out the property in person, have we done an in-person check?
Um, and then if so, what was the date, um, that it's scheduled for
Uh, on the tc
And then who will be present?
Is, are we expecting the tenant or anybody to be present at that time?
Um, property access, so do we have full access exterior only because maybe there's a tenant in there
So we're going to look outside, blah, blah, blah, blah, um, and then lockbox key availability
Okay, and then lockbox code and then, uh, field visit notes, whoever goes out there
Once we get that text message back about the property condition, like what, what was actually going on at the property
Like, hey, the tenant's actually a real a-hole, you know, or whatever, you know
Um, there's squatters in the property, blah, blah, blah, blah, okay, so you put those under there
All right, so, um, this is, um
Custom fields, uh, I happen to believe that it's probably one of the most important things that you can implement into your business
When it comes to your lead management process and your overall flow
Because it handles the handoff for you
All right, this person actually said stop
I just realized
Are we DNC'd? No
So, uh, get this stuff out of the message board as much as possible and get it into these custom fields
I promise you it will help a ton
Um, and so now let's just real quickly go through a record going through this flow
In fact, we can just use this, um, that not interested
Because, uh, not that one
Well, I don't know which one it was
This one
Right, can I go back?
Perfect, okay, so let's just use this one. So, this one I'm gonna do
Um, I'm gonna pretend like hey, I'm a cold car and I turn this person into not interested
Okay, and I'm actually gonna I'm just gonna like or I turn this person to a lead and I'm just gonna go through the flow
We're just gonna, you know, reference our
You know document here and we will move them through the pipeline as expected. Okay, so very first thing
I just clicked on it. I call the number
Um
I get them on the phone. They're interested in selling so I'm gonna do a
Um, stab them, right? So I'm gonna change status to, uh, new lead
Check to make sure the task is added. I'm gonna complete my task on it
That's an old task
You know board add my notes
Update my custom fields as part of the board
Okay, and then once that happens now as a lead manager as a caller like I've done my job
Right and so now it's a j. It's got a new lead on it
And it's got the the task on it and it's got the it's on the board
Right the next thing that we do is we update our lead summary
We grabbed this address. We put it in our lead summary document
Um
And I'm not gonna have time to do that on this call but on the next in two weeks for now when we cover lead management again
Um, this will go a bit quicker because we'll shop up the front 30 minutes
And we'll add on some kpi and and uh stuff at the back end, okay
Um
And so now as a lead manager what I would do is I you know when I wake up as a lead manager
I'm coming here and I'm gonna I'm gonna look at my task due today. Right going through my flow. I would
on my daily
Uh
Flow I would have already done my clear and now I got a new lead
Right and so I'm gonna come in here. I'm gonna have my lead management. Of course. I'd have it as a quick filter
click apply
I do not know what record that was
It's probably this one 905 days ago. Okay, and so I'm gonna open it up
Yep, this is the one and so I'm gonna call them
Okay, and I'm just gonna pretend like this person doesn't answer initially
Um check what board it's on look at my tasks
Uh, check out my messages, you know standard stuff and then I call them
They don't answer and so I complete my task and then I'm gonna move them to my next phase. No contact new lead
Right, that's gonna change my status
To no contact new lead. It's gonna add my task for no contact new lead and now
And copy this address. Uh, I'm gonna click on my records page
And I'm gonna pretend like I'm now coming in to do my unqualified follow up
Right because now I have to do unqualified tasks. So I'm gonna come in here
I'm gonna do my unqualified follow-ups
And in this case, I'm gonna say to do because um
It's due tomorrow and it won't show up if I don't do that
So I'm gonna click apply
And then I'm just gonna filter by that address real quick
So I can show you guys it and there's that record, right?
And so tomorrow this would show up under my due today. Okay, so I'm gonna select it
And I'm gonna stab him and look at my status. Okay. I'm gonna look at my my boards
I got my task on here. All right, like my messages. Let me call him
Um, and after I call him, let's just pretend like it's been five days
Okay, and I can see that because on my activity log, I would see that I completed if that let's just simulate it
I complete the task
And for five days he sits under here. So there's one day
Complete the task
Okay, there's two days because it's been completed two times there's two days
Uh, let's say three days. Let's say I just leave him in here for three days
Okay, so I just I just came in for three days in a row you and I just went through time for three days
And um, we completed this task and called this seller
We go to call him again and we realize like hey like this property looking at it in sift map
It's actually a good property. Um, but it's got a 70 AI score on it and it definitely needs a new roof and
Got new windows on it though. Anyway, uh, what's the list on on it? They can
Absentee owner. So let's pretend like we don't care about this record
Right. We're gonna say that this record needs to go to a weekly follow-up after three attempts
Okay
So what we do is we just move it to the nurture new lead phase because that's our weekly cadence, right?
Um, and now that record is is is going to show up again under my unqualified filter
Remember because that filter because it is an unqualified
Uh, yeah
Status right no contact new lead means unqualified. It just has two different tasks on it
So if I filtered by my unqualified lead tasks
um to do
It's gonna include records that are due today and do in a week from now
right because
the status is
Unqualified
But the task cadence is just going to show up on
Do today whichever one is due right? So this one's not due until the 23rd
All right. Um, and so what we'll do is we just filter by that record
Okay, select it again stab them status
Task board messages and we can see that this lead is that was the record on the 23rd
Okay, and so I would continue to complete this task as an unqualified task until basically I decide that
It's time to move this guy to you know, uh to ghosting right which could be three to six months
Um really preference. All right. Um, you can always filter by
Your property meta events and you can see to know how long this has been unqualified
If you're curious as a lead manager
Instead of showing all events just switch it to property meta events and look at the date that it moved to no contact new lead
So april 15. So if it's four months from now, I'm like, okay. Yeah, this guy needs the move to ghosting
Right. I'm literally just going to click my drop down
Move from the ghosting
That's going to update my status and do everything that needs to be get done based on the default build. Okay
Um, but let's just say this person becomes a lead, right? I call him right now
I'm finally he picks up the phone. I qualify him. So I'm going to change it
I'm going to move them to say warm leads
Which is going to change my task
to warm
And it's going to update my status if I refresh my screen here to a warm lead
Right. So now when I come to do my qualified follow-ups in four in 15 days from now
Um
I would click on qualified follow-ups and again, I'm gonna switch it to to do
click apply
In 15 days from now this record will show up
Underneath of the qualified follow-ups
Right because it's time to call this person again because their status is warm
Um, and they're got a warm task on it. It's on the other warm phase. This is a qualified follow-up, right?
And so I'm going to call them and I'm going to keep doing that until I get a hold of them
I'm gonna keep texting them and I'm keep nurturing them and until they progress from warm to hot or warm to send out positions
Once I send this to acquisitions, I just go like, okay, this person's ready for an offer
So I'm a stab. I'm going to complete my task
Um add my notes, you know this whole time. I'm updating my quote my custom fields
I'm going to move them to send the acquisitions as soon as I do that
And I refresh his record
It's going to now be under the acquisitions board underwriting phase. Now. This is something
Specific to me
We have an underwriting phase you guys it'll go straight to a point we make offer
Okay, this is another one of those things that's acquisitions on whether you want to underwrite not underwrite
And how you want to do that flow
We start off in underwriting and then we move things to a point make offer nowadays, okay?
So
Um, we move it to a point make offer or underwriting either way. It's the start of the acquisition cycle
Let's just pretend because we're not going to cover this now
Um that this person doesn't respond blah blah blah blah and so therefore they need to be sent back to lee management
What it's going to do is i'm going to move them down here. Click send back to lee management
Refresh my screen here and you're going to see that
This will now be underneath my lead manager needs review and I have my send back to lee management task
What is my lead manager supposed to do every single day is check my send back to lee management task so that he can come in here
And he can say okay. Well, we offer this much. We look at the messages. We look at everything that happened
You know like okay. Well, i'm just going to move this guy i'm going to complete my send back to lee management
I'm going to consider this guy cold lead now
As soon as I do that and move him back to that phase the status changed to cold lead
And now I have my cold follow-up task on here and it's back in my qualified follow-ups for cold status
Okay
Meanwhile every day
I am checking is there anything without tasks on it and my stab in the records and i'm building that discipline throughout the business
Okay, so what i'm going to do is i'm going to delete this from this board
That my team doesn't actually call it i'm going to delete this task
And i'm going to change the status back to not interested
And i'm going to remove the assignee so that this records back
And i'm also going to put this as dnc correct number because they did say stop
Okay, and that's me stabbing the record just now
in iRL
Okay, so
That is an example of the flow
A couple items here
If you make an offer always track your offer progress that offer through to a deal blah blah blah
That's an acquisitions function
And then of course always update your custom fields
And the advanced investor as you progress is so you have a i data and stuff is
You would start creating hierarchies
So for example out of your cold leads
If you have a cold lead
And let's just like open this one up real quick and open in sift map
As an example
It's an ai score 57. It's a cold lead
Um, it has no distressers on it. So am i going to consider this a warm lead by default?
No, all right, let's click on another one just see
Let's click on uh someone who is a hot lead
Just out of curiosity and open it up in new tab and see
Notice this one
um is an ai score of 97
And uh, you can see what it looks like, right a little bit more things
So, you know, it's a hot lead because we prioritize them because our ai scores kind of help us filter out all of those
leads
Which we should be surfacing to being more warm with higher cadences because they have an ai likelihood of selling as well
So as you progress as an investor as you keep, you know working with us and expanding inside the product
um, you'll notice that your ai scores also start incorporating into your lee management cycles in order to
um help filter up the cadence that you're uh focusing on because
If you were to filter by i'm just going to give you guys an example here real quick
um, let's take uh
Um
Let's just take that one. What ad what what zip code was this y'all don't steal this hot lead. Okay, my
My team would be really pissed off at me. Okay. Um, so
I'm just going to show you why and how that's valuable. Okay, and then we'll we'll we'll kind of finish up here
I apologize for being 30 minutes over the first ones and usually all of them happen that way
So, uh, but hopefully you guys got some value from it. Um, so what we're going to do is we're going to look at this and see
Does this matter and if we go to solve properties and we look at
um
And do vault county
Okay, and we grab that zip code
Oh
Is that not do vault what
Might have been hillsboro
Yeah, it was okay. We go to hillsboro county. We go back the last six months
Okay, and now let's look at just single family residences
And apply that
So what we see when we do this is that
88% of the investor transactions that sold inside that zip code
We predicted had over a 50 AI score. Okay, so now if you look dang it
No
Remember the address did it say save it no
Hold on. Hold on. I want the address real quick property address. Wait, did I say now I saved the zip code
mailing address
too partial
okay
This one
D I don't remember what address was but
Um, what we could look at is we can then also look at the distressors
Right, and we can see what what what distresses were on it. I know this one was um, I'm pretty sure this was probate absentee
Um, you know absentee is 52 percent
Um, it had high equity on it
Um, they were senior owners, you know, and so we can see that
If I just look at my leads and I do start getting to point where I have AI scores in that area
Um, I can prioritize those leads and have a really high
Confidence of which leads I should be focusing most in my energy on because clearly this is a great zip
code, uh, inside Hillsborough
Um, the investor transactions are very clear
We have a high prediction rate and most of the the deals that are selling to investors do have a high AI score
And so the question is how many of my leads inside
My account right now are we following up with on a regular basis that are
are um
Less than a 50 AI score in that same location
When like under warm lead when they should be under cold for example, right?
And so you can reprioritize your tempo then based on
Looking at sold properties and your market analysis
And the neighborhoods that they're in and all of these other parameters that I teach you guys in the market analysis training
Which is why i'm bringing this up like if you've done the market analysis training
You should have a top 20 neighborhoods inside your market
You should have a top three to five zip codes
And you should have a resource for your lee manager and you can just give this to claud after I give you guys
This file and say hey
Create a resource for my lead manager to cross reference
So that when we generate leads we can prioritize them in these locations, right?
So then the lead manager when they go to you know, click on a lead
They can see is it in the top neighborhood because if it is even if the person doesn't want to sell right away
We can consider them a higher priority
Then the ones that want to sell immediately but are probably in like a shitty location and they're just tire kicking
Right and so it's all about resource allocation making sure my team is focused on the most highest value prospects
In leads as much as possible from the marketing side down to the acquisitions, okay?
All righty then
Let's see this video or a replay will be available for us to reference in future. Yep
It'll be saved inside the help center you guys will have this training and again every two weeks
I'll be doing this training again and every two it's alternating now every
Two weeks we're alternating between the market analysis and the lead management and you can see that in our customer calendar
So if you save the customer calendar and the email that you guys receive for the reminder of this at the bottoms of customer
Counterlink open that up save it to your google calendar that way you can see which Wednesday is what training and feel free to come attend
You know every month or a couple months to see what's changed or updated
We'll keep you guys up to date on
the new and important things to be adopting into your business
um
Also on that help center article will be the link to download
the resources for this and i'll include a loom video on how to add the skill and go through that process of um
of
updating the training manual to your business and then um how to get
Claude to create the custom fields for you in your account
Which trust me there's 75 of them it saves a lot of time you work on something else while it does it
it's kind of cool actually
Cool anybody have any remaining questions
There you go kylee just shared
um
The link to the google calendar
All
Perfect. All right, you don't have a
Oh, good. All right quick question
um leads that come in that aren't in your just call it your bibox like you you got them or whatever
They're in date. They're in data. Sif. What do you do to them? Do you mark them dead?
You just leave them there with no status. Do you remove them?
I haven't been removing them because I don't want to have to reevaluate them again
Yeah, so what you can turn on your bibox just move them as dead lien
um
and in our
I didn't cover the google sheet. Um that we update for lead summary, but in our lead summary
Um
We cover all this next the next version of this training. I'll cover the that that lead summary document
Um, but what it does is it has like the date that it becomes a dead lead and the reasoning
Um as well that way in the future and and of course you could create a custom field for this as well
It's actually something that I probably should do
Um, but I I just haven't um so that you wait the status is dead lead you can have a uh
um a dead lead status reasoning that way
You know, you can make sure that if this person ever comes into your your ecosystem again
If the status is already dead lead it's gonna update the new lead again
Like if it comes in for your website or whatever, but then you can just look at the custom fields and see this was a dead lead on this date
Um and therefore it's probably still a dead lead
Um, but yeah, you don't want to delete it out your account because the fact is is it's gonna end up back in your account again
If they re-enter your cycle, so
And do you update if a house sold at all or tag it some way so, you know, it's sold so I mean this is long term
So two years from now, maybe
Someone's flipping it or they never flipped it and it's back in the lead again and you would have bought it
But it sold to someone else six months ago, right?
Yeah, so if it's sold we move it to lost deal and uh the status changes to to lost deal
um
We're right now as a data sift as a company. We are working on building out the auto updating your records page real time functionality
um, so
Um, if something ended up having a sold date
Uh once it does have that sold date
So if you just focus on moving at the lost deal for now
Once our data updates that that property sold it's going to prompt it you to update that sold date and reset the record
So from your lead manager's perspective
They don't got to worry about that because we're building out that process
Um, because sometimes you'll have cold leads that end up selling you don't even know that they sold and so
um, there'll be someone on your team that's responsible for
Um processing those records some things will auto update
Um, those there's a settings page for it where like your bedrooms and bathrooms your estimated values all this stuff is going to update your data
You know automatically, but if something had a sold date change or if an owner changed from what's inside your system
It's going to prompt you to a manual update and reset the record as as however you want
Um, so
Uh, so yeah, so for now just worry about that. But otherwise just move it to to to sold
Um, or i'm sorry lost deal and and track that. Yeah
All right. Thanks man. Yep. Cool
Awesome everybody. Well, I appreciate you guys time. Thanks for hanging out with me for three and a half hours when you could have
I mean, you could have been with tie you chose me. So I appreciate that
uh
today if you were on the deal flow challenge and
Uh, you want to watch recording. I definitely recommend it
He's covered. I think he covered some new updates like deep prospecting flows and things like that. So, um,
Maybe, uh after you get some some work done for the rest of the days and so it took you for three and a half hours
Uh, you can check that out, but
Um, I appreciate y'all's time enjoy the rest of your week and if you need anything you guys know how to reach us that talked us
But in the top right corner, we're here to help out the best we can all right
later